[Music]
candidate hakayinde chilema is promising
to create jobs for zambia's jobless
youth unemployment hit a 10-year high
last year there's been anger and
frustration about the economy that's why
supporters of ichilema's opposition
united party for national development
are confident he can beat incumbent
president edgar lungu so he's scared of
president taka in the city because
sanity is going to return this country
these guys
they have committed so many offenses
there are too much fraud cases so they
are scared to hand over power but the
zambian people through the borrowed
paper we will make sure that
they hand over power
[Music]
president lungu's backers say they are
not worried their candidate plans to
increase their control of the mines as
well as development projects built by
his government and paid for by debt
zambia has more than 12 billion dollars
of external debt as well as an unknown
amount of debt to china
but lungu's governing party supporters
believe the new roads bridges power
stations hospitals and airports are
worth it all the people do in the
opposition is to accuse us of corruption
to accuse us of stealing to accuse us of
things that they cannot even quantify so
the losing aspect is not in our
vocabulary because we've tested the
ground we've heard what people are
saying
corruption is another issue for voters
western donors have suspended aids to
zambia saying they are concerned about
financial mismanagement if we do not
tackle corruption then you'll find that
we've got a distortion within the
economy and we have seen this in the
last years that the people that seem to
have the resources in the country are
not the private sector who run
businesses but people who are affiliated
to political parties and this is
speaking to corruption which is really
negative to economic growth the country
is relatively calm but analysts predict
this is going to be a hotly contested
election
after thursday's vote if no candidate
secures an outright majority in the
first round then a runoff has to take
place five years ago president edgar
lungu narrowly defeated his rival
hakayinde chilema a result the
opposition said was rigged but they
failed to overturn it in court there
have been some incidents of violence by
governing party and opposition
supporters across the country in the
run-up to thursday's vote that's why
president lunku said he deployed the
military to maintain peace but many
zombies fear there could be more
political violence if the election
results are disputed haru mutasa al
jazeera lusaka